[Music]
welcome
to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live lord cognito
here i love podcast lawyergaming.net
and who are these fine people in the
realm of playing nyc today
hi my name's uh jesse niggit i'm one of
the programmers for
squish and this fine lady in the room hi
i'm athene yip i am the producer for
squish and also the lead environment
artist
nice now squish looks very very cool
i need to learn what this game is about
can you tell us what is the premise of
squish
yeah so uh pretty much these uh
skelegoose are obsessed with raving
but the venue can't handle it so all the
blocks are coming down and like
pretty much falling on top of them and
so the skeletoos need to survive the
rave pretty much so they got to survive
the raid
and now again the mechanics multiplayer
now
what are the core mechanics of the game
for each player
so core mechanics you're basically
pushing and manipulating the terrain
which is the block over here
you try to squish other players to be
the last one standing
basically it's a great rave gone awry
and you want to be the last player
standing to escape
this crumbling mausoleum i love the rave
concert i think that that's hilarious so
tell us about development
how long has this game been developed is
it out now or like just tell us that
whole process with development
yeah sure so we actually started off as
a student game
in uc santa cruz back in like late 2018
and then we were developing for maybe
like six months
and we ended up going to e3 for the
college game
and we ended up as a finalist and then
after that we've just been
like been developing until now and our
game is going to come out
probably early 2022 okay so we're
getting there yeah
the art style looks fantastic very
colorful very very
i love the dj in the back dj the back is
awesome love we love we love we love the
dj
so that's number one but um again like
it's just a very vibrant cool art style
what i was gonna say is like as far as
platforms what are we looking at
go ahead jesse platforms well there we
actually have uh
multiple maps and so uh each arena has
their own twist
crystal caves is uh similar to this game
mode but like the platform just keeps on
shrinking and shrinking
there's no wall they can fall off into
the water and skele
can't swim
so how many stages are we looking are we
looking at multiple stages like what are
we looking at
five five or six seven yeah for now yeah
yeah and then we're
thinking of of course adding more yeah
in the future for sure
it's pretty different so again we have
classic and crystal caves which is kind
of
more of our original concept and then we
have a low gravity one called space rays
we also have like single player which is
also kind of a co-op mode
yes and then we also have like a coin
grab mode and a person of interest mode
what's the person of interest person of
interest basically you're trying to hit
a specific block and you're scoring
points that way
everyone else is trying to come at you
with switches so it's like a 3v1
exactly exactly yeah that's pretty cool
very unique concept
i mean the name is fitting scratch
absolutely absolutely so let me ask you
this like during the pandemic obviously
you know as far as game development how
has that affected you as a studio
working on this game
right um actually so we went remote
before the pandemic
because we started off as a student game
and we all split
um just you know going back to our
hometowns we were already a remote so by
the time the pandemic rolled around we
already had a lot of
like practices and processes in place
which made it really easy and i think
another thing is that like the team that
we're working with like
we're so blessed to have them each
person is so valuable
and they bring a lot to the team a
really close knit so i think a lot of
that
just like personality and how we mesh
together is really important as well
yeah i would assume communication zoom
calls
you know all that you know during it but
now it's like hopefully things get
better
you know is that helping is is
conditions improving helping it
cross the finish line maybe in 2022
possibly what we're looking at
i'd say so yeah but we already have like
we already have like so many processes
like
we got kind of got it down whatever got
it
we got it yeah nice we're pretty excited
about it pm students looks
really cool you got everybody playing
having a good time
so again we're looking at maybe again
top of 2022
possibly maybe that's
a general time frame all right cool and
again initially are we coming out pc
what are we what are we looking at as
far as pc
and then uh hopefully we'll just switch
oh okay okay we like that like marketing
likes that
yeah that's did you look i think
i think this will be perfect for switch
to be honest you know i mean obviously
we get it out when we can get it out of
the platforms we can but again
this type of art style that cooperative
aspect let me ask you one quick question
um
is it will there is it is it local co-op
only oh that
is that's the focus right now or is it
something online at some point
so we have local co-op down really well
and right now we're implementing online
multiplayer so we'll have both
so you can have the best of both worlds
yeah
we love netcode and we would love to
play this with friends
against you so that's actually an
awesome awesome thing so you heard it
first development from squish
look for it again hopefully top of 2022
pc first
switch maybe hopefully nintendo get on
it
and you heard it here first awesome game
looks fantastic
thank you so much you already switched